hey everybody it's me and I'm back from
the dead this is unbelievable my tour
solo is on pause because the Impractical
Jokers national tour has started the
arena tour tickets are on sale for the
first leg of it right now at impractical
jokerslive.com we're coming to Reading
Pennsylvania we're coming to uh Stony
Brook we're coming to Pittsburgh Camden
New Jersey Boston we're coming to
Charleston South Carolina Charlotte
North Carolina Waterloo New York uh
Washington DC Niagara Falls Newark
Wallingford Belmont Park we're playing
that UBS Arena and the Prudential arena
in Jersey Island Milwaukee Rosemont
Seattle Portland I mean guys Utah Denver
Arlington Austin Sugar Land Columbus
Cleveland Detroit Minneapolis Des Moines
Kansas City I'm getting tired Nashville
Indianapolis and St Louis that's just
what's announced right now and it's all
on sale right now we're revving up right
now the show's gonna be a blast we
haven't been out in years hope to see
you there in practicejokerslive.com
what's up baby a brand new hour of
stand-up material go to chrisdcomedy.com
for Ticky Wiki's January 12th in New
Orleans January 13th in Dallas is sold
out January 14th in Houston is almost
sold out or might be sold out and then
January 26th to the 28th Phoenix Arizona
brand new hour of stand up come check it
[Music]
out
hey babe little bit of dressing hey babe
little bit of flexing hey babe little
bit of dressing hey babe little bit of
flexing I went to the store for some
chocolate flavored milk came home with a
thick chocolate covered MILF hey hey
babe hey babe so first question how was
the afterlife yes so actually it's crazy
on November 2nd on November 2nd at 1 18
PM I passed away right uh it was they
didn't know what it was at first until
the autopsy you're right uh they did the
autopsy what what happened
turned out old age wow it's just natural
causes okay Naturals it was nothing
specific yeah and so that began what
became an eight-week intensive research
study right while I was passed right on
how to bring me back from old age and
I'm happy to say that I don't know what
happened in the last eight weeks yeah it
feels like I died yesterday but right
this morning right they brought me back
up and the first thing I did was text
you guys and you said we can do an
episode today yeah and so I came here
yeah but just so you know I feel like
I'm like 18 years old again they replace
some things you well you look as soon as
you walked in the first thing I said is
that he you look fantastic you don't
have any dirt on you anywhere hold on
birth control birth control oh [ __ ] I
forgot my meds at home oh my God you're
gonna die again
oh well that's that I can do about that
so well here's the here's the good news
about this if you die you've been
through it before yeah you did it once
you could do it again because
the thing was is when you died on
November 2nd of 118 yeah we showed up to
your house with aluminum foil because we
were like we're gonna wrap you up like
the fish and put it in the refrigerator
I had to walk in freezer yes
that's what we were going to do when we
thought it'd be great and then we and
then but they had buried your body
already but I'm I'm happy to know
we weren't sure we weren't sure what it
is but um you know we're just happy
we're happy you're back when you're
still alive a few things gave out at the
same time as what happened so what have
I missed you missed a lot of money first
of all svelte well thank you happy you
bring that up I'd like to talk to you
take a moment to talk to you about
intermittent fasting yeah provided by
better help oh nice no I uh so what I've
been doing and I know you know listen
first of all for the people who are
yelling at their I mean I've been gone
eight weeks I came back I noticed a
difference Sal's been dead so I have to
take him through my spiritual journey by
the way do you know how many people that
I just I when I got up this morning
how many people told me I was dead
somebody texted me
a friend of a family texted me R.I.P my
condolences
no yeah dude so many people will like
are you alive are you are you really are
you alive or are you dead and they don't
I was keeping it under wraps no I
thought well listen we kept the secret
of sound being dead because each week I
would tell them unfortunately sound
passed away but he will be here next
week
um but but I appreciate you saying Alex
felt I've been doing intermittent
fasting right now I I download this app
called the zero fasting app okay which
is not a sponsor and they don't want to
be a sponsor we've reached out so but
you know but that's how much I believe
in this product even though they have uh
well their competitor app brought me
back to life so maybe we go with them
there you go exactly boom so if you
listen in zero don't be a zero so what
time do you eat like five minutes a day
so no no no no so actually yes like take
for example yesterday I went to a
actually brand new French restaurant in
the city of here it's called faquettes
no it's French I guess it's like you
pronounce it like like you would
pronounce croquette but [ __ ] what okay
[ __ ] no it doesn't sound appetizing if
I'm being honest Focus brazieri right
brought the Brazil and it's a new hotel
called for Quest so it's a hotel slash
restaurant well it's a brand new hotel
in Tribeca try back and and for quetz
tribecs
for Quest Drive X and I actually made
the reservation
um I'm sorry the people who made the
reservation uh for us went out with uh
our neighbors they actually it's so
complicated the website we actually had
a 6 p.m reservation in Paris it was a
six pm with the four question guys
that's not true I swear to God we got
that we have no information you did not
have a reservation here and then the
guy's like no I made a reservation he
goes he goes oh you're the reservation
in Paris at six million he goes
otherwise it is it is Midnight in Paris
I don't think you will make it and you
were like we were like he's like oh
let's see if we can find a table and
then they found a table for us I was
like [ __ ] wait what happened in the
last eight weeks that now you're going
to a French fine dining restaurants
while I'm gone Everything's changed what
I mean we're having a Bloom Cafe
everything everything Everything's
changed yeah you yeah well that's
because there's more portions French
well actually but this place for quetz
is like a French almost like a French
diner in a way they would get upset if I
said that because it's classy and nice
but it's like a um is it like Balthazar
uh yes it's kind of like a a yes and I
treat it for quotes like James Gordon
treated baltazar okay right yeah yeah
yeah just just yelling at everybody
treating them like they were underlying
yeah I threw [ __ ] egg whites at the
waiter yes this is what we heard this is
oh you know let's just make sure we say
it allegedly uh welcome back yeah um so
um I did feel like Chris was absorbing
some of your energy when you died so
well because I was going to French
restaurants and I was kind of being you
I was because you had told me that you
had went to French places and done that
so I said if Sal's dead then I'm not
going to let his presence die here on
Earth I'm gonna be sad and it's so nice
because not a lot of people get to come
back yeah I'll tell you what not since
you've been dead for eight weeks I have
not let one pointed pillow point at me
not [ __ ] one so much not once I
slapped them all out of the way got him
out of the way and I haven't done it and
so what brought you to forquest how did
you find out about it and why and and
and do was it a special occasion are you
just doing things now I just said I'm
gonna live my life yeah and I'm gonna do
things because I said I see how quickly
life can be taken from you that's what
happened to you for the last two weeks
I'm so I'm so glad no I am so glad yeah
now they buried me fully that's why I
said I can't believe it
fully buried but they just someone got a
Google alert that they they they they
found like the cute like the cute old to
what I had they just did it by the way
by the way it was it was just a little
bit of like ointment and a couple of
stitches that's all it wasn't a big
secret and uh they dug me back up and uh
yeah they pumped me full I got a
transfuse yeah and uh you know like I
said I I remember October 31st in Priya
yeah November 2nd and prior well yeah a
lot a lot what's really happened in the
world since Sal's been dead what's the
big news sunberg has become a Power
Player in society oh yeah it's Greta
Thunder that was happening before me but
now yeah but now now it's like what
happened after my passing so but well
this is more recent in this let's go
back to the start at the beginning we're
all over the place as I like it but
again how did you hear about Focus okay
let me yeah let me ask you let me answer
your question is I is Is frequent is I
suggested to our neighbors who are great
people Lebanese people great Lebanese
people love Lebanon shout out Lebanon
shout out beiru shout out Shawarma
hummus um what else is Lebanon libyans
Lebanon or Lebanese oh Libya is libyans
yes
but shout out to me as well I'm still
getting everything back you know it's
hard you know I'm just thinking the
libyans run for it Marty which you
probably don't even know that reference
no but Back to the Future but it's okay
one day you'll understand Love Back to
the Future you know about bequettes but
you don't know about I know it back to
the future but but so so so Lebanese so
you want to did you want to seem like
you were uh worldly I wanted to say to
like you know let's not I'm not going to
suggest you know even though I love
ballados you know it's Italian place
great restaurants but we always go there
these are high-end Lebanese people yeah
treat them right right what and I said
and I just suggested I just put it in
the chat I said what about French food
okay what about French food you have a
chat with your Lebanese neighbors yes
I'm in a group chat with the Lebanese
neighbors okay and I said what'd you
name it
um we actually haven't named it yet we
haven't named but it's just it's just
our three names but we should actually
know how about love with these nuts
you can clip it will they take offense
no no no great oh great so don't do that
great and you know what's great about
these neighbors is the the guy the the
the the the husband he has drinks but
never drunk he's the designated driver
always so we can you can get smashed
you're going all over town with this guy
yes and he always and he has he drives
he can't be in the passenger seat so he
has to drive why can't he just gets like
you know maybe car sick or something so
he Dr he so it it's never like oh hey
maybe you drive this week you'd be the
DD he always drives wait wait hold on a
second you're acting you the way you're
speaking sounds like this is how you've
hung out there many times no no no we've
done French food with them last night we
did um Italian food with them we've went
to um we went to a um uh uh uh uh what
else do we go we did French food we did
it and we did Italian food twice we went
to the place on Staten Island um Venom
oh yeah but I couldn't I like that place
but they serve rabbit and I can't do
exotic meats like that no I don't I
can't do it no I'll never have a rabbit
can't eat around I wouldn't even need a
duck someone tried to get me to the duck
yesterday well that's all they serve in
the French restaurants is duck all they
wanted to give you is Duck and snails
and I'm like I'd lie I don't want Duncan
snails right now they're quackers
quackers so duck and snail who so I I
eat duck before snail maybe yeah
escargot is an S car no yeah people told
me that
[Laughter]
Duckett can [ __ ] it yeah you could yeah
like Duck is delicious you eat other
birds I'm like yeah but we've been
trained for the other birds yes I can't
just just make a left turn and start
eating a quail yeah and it's also like
I'm not gonna eat a duck because it's
like I read about ducks to my
one-year-old for her bedtime stories I'm
not gonna eat animals from her bedtime
stories yeah but this is probably a
chicken bedtime story no you know you
almost never see a chicken bedtime story
really no no disclosure I've had a quail
egg interesting what'd you think what'd
you think of the dance it tasted like an
egg yeah I I think that honestly if
we're going to talk about meats and all
that and how horrible slaughterhouse all
that stuff I get it but I mean nothing's
worse than the egg I mean you're
literally you're eating an unborn baby
and you and it's breakfast nothing is
worse than the egg and people don't talk
about it enough people don't talk about
it they just scramble them they just
scramble them it's brutal I mean if
you're eating a a you know in an egg I
mean I guess you wouldn't ever put egg
on a chicken I guess like you would
never get like a chicken cut and put an
egg on it if you did you've eaten a
whole family yeah you're Jeffrey Dahmer
oh yeah that's like the worst it's like
the mother and the kid you eat the
mother and the kid but the egg is not a
baby either yet until something happens
no I think that that would go have gone
on too fast no no no no no Are We Wrong
on that don't tell me that I'm almost I
mean what do you mean all right because
the egg comes out
well then what happens if they you mean
to tell me
that we're just eating it quick enough
that it doesn't turn again
or whatever the goose whatever that is
if it's sat on that just a few days
longer that would have formed into a
chicken
what's the gestation period
because most eggs sold commercially are
not fertilized but it does sound like a
couple oh so those are dropping eggs no
matter what I was gonna so there's no
chance if I bought a carton eggs and I
forgot about it for three weeks and then
I want to make an omelet I could open
this there's never be it they'll never
be a live chicken inside it's human
error Maybe
human era it says most so maybe a few
minutes
so we want you to go right on the hey
babe comments right now have you ever
forgotten about your acorns and you want
to go make an omelette and there was a
live Chicken in your fridge if so what
did you do with it also Joe's baby
chicks uh name another thing as cute and
adorable as them name one I'll wait uh a
puppy isn't even cute as cute as it when
a chick is born when a chick is born
that big and they just like they're all
like the hair looks like a light socket
right and they're just like looking
around so gorgeous I would say the only
thing as cute as maybe a baby chick are
are Asian babies yeah Asian babies the
number one baby the number one cutest
baby I understand why people adopt them
left and right I understand I I love I
would love the opportunity to have an
Asian baby couldn't agree more they get
away with anything I say I throw in
Black in Asians okay black babies and
Asian babies you know what's tough as a
parent you won't know if they're ugly
till later because they all come out
great yeah I never seen I've never seen
an ugly black baby I've never seen ugly
Asian baby but I see ugly Asian in black
adults and which is interesting what
happens you're not going to know and
imagine thinking for five ten years that
you have the most adorable kid and then
or something something happens and
you're like oh my God there's a curse
really it is a curse but I could could
you see quite a lot of ugly white babies
yeah oh you see white babies right out
there right out the coach yeah brutal
yeah yeah you'll come out and I'll be
like okay yeah you want to be like yeah
I swear to God my friend had just had a
baby a little baby boy the baby looks
like exactly to like a 40 year old
Kramer he looks like what Kramer looked
like in season three of Seinfeld
holy [ __ ] yeah okay so let's get you
want to get back to for questions I have
so much going around in my head I I
don't know how to process it it's just
so good to see you because I I can't
it's unbelievable like we pimp show me a
video of um of uh um Mr Beast the big
YouTuber okay he buried himself alive
for 48 hours and it's like you've buried
Yourself Dead for eight weeks yeah I try
to try 60 days try 60 days of in in the
afterlife also he was he a lot he had
what water and air he had water and air
you were fully dead I was dead
now did you get a haircut in there you
didn't not real though they cut my hair
for the fume oh they cut yo yeah and
they did because it looks I love your
hair thanks so much I I yeah I mean yeah
all right how was the Rose's eulogy
I I'm telling you I went I went dark you
didn't hear anything I didn't hear
anything yeah you got footage yeah well
you're not there I thought it'd be
disrespectful yeah
I heard there was complaints
right there was complaints well the bad
news is to Rosa now I know you never
know but DeRosa now has taken over taste
buds and DeRosa now does he does taste
buds from Joey roses it's actually now
it's he just calls it taste bud okay
it's just tasty argues with himself
I heard he did at the funeral I heard he
did a pine versus an oak coffin yes and
it and and and people were you know
livid with him
um but there's it's interesting because
people thought you got cremated too
there's somebody uh we actually somebody
gave your family an urn so I don't know
what ashes are in there I have no idea
what's in there but we watched that
someone gave your family wild so it's
weird but you were buried you said I
think I had like uh they tried to do
that I'm a little bit like uh what's his
name that they tore a statue Down
Columbus no no bad guy more recent uh
dictator uh Stalin Hitler uh mustache
Hitler no no no no no Stalin oh the most
recent guy Gaddafi no no 20 years later
Vladimir Putin no no he was down they
took him down they pulled them down with
the ropes in the Middle East he killed
them I think too and dragged them
through the through the woods isn't that
Gaddafi no the
that's it name this episode Saddam
Hussein shout out Saddam Hussein shout
out did you be watching and we and we we
don't we don't know if you are because
this is what I was gonna say he had all
those doubles those body doubles so when
he leaves the premises of a place there
was like eight Saddam Hussein's and they
all got into different Vehicles right we
did a little experiment like that so
maybe they were trying to pull us faster
when they handed people the urn Saddam
Hussein in the afterlife no I'm telling
you I went dark you don't you didn't wow
maybe you were in purgatory is that
possible he didn't go you didn't go to
heaven or hell and that is now only one
person came to me who in the in the sick
in the eight weeks one person who was it
because I think she oversees something
down there Kane Tanaka just like the
gate like the gatekeeper oh you went
down down there well oh I don't know did
you have a subconscious
did you yeah did you did you see did you
tell Kane Tanaka that we I don't know if
we discovered this in the eight weeks
you were dead or not but there is an
older person named Kane Tanaka yeah she
told me [ __ ] yeah how old is that person
now they're like 119 or 120. well Kane
to Knox was 116. right she said [ __ ] 120
year old [ __ ] that's what she said wow
yeah interesting yeah with uh yeah I
mean Kane Kane Tanaka we haven't spoken
about here I will say one thing we did
do to observe your death and honor you
is in this last eight weeks we never
started the episode with his song we
never talked about Kane Tanaka we never
did any of the things that you and I
used to do we didn't we didn't do any of
that we did keep 100 of the ad money but
we didn't do
imagine living double the expectation
I am yeah
invested how did you find faquette and
how good is a potato croquette okay so I
wanna yes so a potato croquet a potato
croquette yeah is I personally think the
best appetizer item you can get wow why
not wow and if you have a problem with
that take it up with JoJo Rose's new
show taste buds
so so I I a potato croquette is amazing
so how I got in the two-part question is
for quetz is I said let's get French
food they are neighbors immediately said
I found the best French food because
well a lot of times what you hear about
is very pretentious French food small
portions overpriced blah blah blah
facets was none of this for quetz made
it a point to give you in what they call
American sized portions of great French
cuisine made by a French chef so French
that I actually accidentally booked
myself in Paris right so
I they came out by the way the French
onion soup that I had which was just
called onion soup there the onion soup
that I had is it really just cold onions
swear to God yeah because they felt it
was you know derivative okay so so that
was the best french onion soup I have
ever had in my entire life so much to
the point where I offered my neighbors
who Wanna who one is gluten-free I said
you have to I know it's very weird to
try a soup I said you have to try the
soup would you tell that to the Lebanese
gluten-free guy who insists on driving
yes okay and and and so and so I said
you and Jasmine she was like you can't
offer people soup it's disgusting I said
literally no you didn't know from soup
from your bowl for my bowl I said you
have to that's a full qua if it's a fire
but I did it nobody wanted it but it was
so good I couldn't get an app nobody
wanted it nobody wanted yeah I literally
in the middle of a French restaurant
picked up the Crocket they gave you a
real crock yeah and Shout Out David
shout out David and they gave you a real
I think it's a crock
but I picked it up it's a crock pot
is it a Crocket am I wrong it was a ball
with cheese melted on the outside of it
is it why do people say it's a crock of
[ __ ]
crock pot full of [ __ ] is that means
Croc mean what is Croc yeah a crock of
[ __ ] crocod somebody using a dial Rock
so somebody should give that to somebody
for Christmas take a [ __ ] in your Crocs
Croc of [ __ ]
it's a personal finance app that finds
and cancels your unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps you
lower your bills all in one place if
you're going to get canceled do it with
rocket money help them cancel I threw it
in three things cancel to me what three
things I accidentally had two Hulu
accounts didn't realize that I had I had
a bowl again I was a hole again I
accidentally bought I accidentally
bought um Apple games whoa five bucks a
month like a long time ago I forgot
about it I paid for it for a year and a
half without ever using it true bill uh
sorry rocket money comes in and he saves
you money over three million people have
used rocket money saving the average
person up to 720 a year rocket money
makes canceling subscriptions as easy as
the click of a button that's just find
the subscription you press cancel it's
great they'll find them and they'll
quickly and easily identify the
subscriptions for you so you can stop
paying for them three million people
have used rocket money it's amazing so
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com hey babe that's
rocketmoney.com hey babe what is it
rocketmoney.com hey babe
R.I.P shacky beagleman
say to you please make ship happen yep
ship station ship station baby if you
got an e-commerce business if you have
an upstart anything you're launching
something and you want to ship stuff
this is all you need it Aggregates all
the methods it tells you what is the
cheapest it can it can basically have
you have everything channeling through
one thing yeah all your different
platforms and it doesn't matter whether
you got a side hustle or a giant
Warehouse ship station is for you they
got the best rates in the industry and
they just got even better up to 86
percent off USPS and UPS rates it's not
a question of if you should switch the
ship station it's a question of why
haven't you already yeah when are you
gonna do it even now with the after the
holidays with the returns like
deliveries all that stuff stuck if
that's what yeah
ship station what we love about it is
over 130 000 companies have grown their
e-commerce business it is grow your
e-commerce business with chip station 98
of companies that stick with ship
station for a year become customers for
life it works with Amazon
eBay okay
yeah okay make the New Year your best
year and grow your business with ship
station use promo code hey babe today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial 60 days that's how long I
was dead that's it
shipstation.com promo code hey babe
okay that's it baby better help love
better help we use it you and I both use
it uh we've been using it for years now
um we know so many people that used it
and it literally if mental health is a
is a crisis yes that's going to the
world right now and better help helps
you deal with that Mental Health crisis
guidance counselors that get matched up
to you you can do it from the comfort of
your own home on the internet on Zoom
you don't have to go to a brick and
mortar therapist and talk to someone you
know In the Flesh okay guidance
counselors guidance counselor and
therapists I meant to say God yeah okay
yeah yeah
I don't know that's not what happens
yeah that you're not a kid trying to get
into a college yeah I don't know why I
said
when you're at your best you can do
great things because sometimes life gets
you bogged down you might feel
overwhelmed uh like you're not showing
up in the way that you need to okay
working with the therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
yes okay because when you feel empowered
you're more prepared to take on
everything life throws at you it's
convenient flexible affordable just like
Sal and entirely online if you're
thinking of ever giving therapy an
option you haven't this is a great way
to start better help is a good option
yeah you fill out a brief questionnaire
you get matched with a licensed
therapist and you can switch the efforts
anytime for no additional charge if you
want to live a more empowered life who
does not therapy can get you there is it
betterhelp.com hey babe today to get 10
off big first month that's better help
help.com hey babe
okay but I took the ball yeah and I
drank from at the table
at 7 p.m wow slurped it out it was so
good yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah with a waiter the waiter come up
he's like oh man
I was like yeah he called everybody by
the way I and I and listen I don't
fought for Quests for doing this because
they they it is a French establishment I
know for a fact and it is okay I know
for a fact a [ __ ] a [ __ ] a [ __ ] what
and again I don't want to describe go to
this restaurant this restaurant is
amazing I know for a fact our waiter was
putting on a French accent and was not
actually friends
he looked familiar and Jasmine said he
used to go to the gym in Bay Ridge so
there's no way some french guy who
worked was going to the gym in Bay Ridge
Jazz was like he doesn't have a French
accent so he probably did what uh that
councilman did and lied on his res how
crazy is that guy yeah why so so you
came a lot okay so it's all the news
right now I got I just before I got here
I went through the app yeah the news app
you had to because did you see the
forget that he said that he's what did
he
says
that's cancer yeah she said his mom died
in 9 11. yeah how do you wait a minute
how do you say that your mom died when
she's still alive for 15 years after
that yeah it's crazy oh this is crazy
and then he pushed back in the beginning
he's like I I I could explain everything
but it was just like oh you didn't go to
that school now it's like
his name is George Santos is it is it
George Santos and so what can they do
now because they revoke his well he is
the elected official in in New York I
think he is the he is elected already
it's not like he's running I believe he
was elected like he is the guy he's the
personification of a crock of [ __ ] yes
he is a crock of [ __ ]
George Santos if you don't know this
story lied on his resume about
allegedly lied on his resume about all
types of things going to Harvard
um what uh what law firm he worked for
his mom dying in 911 and he is the now
elected official penis girth
penis girl I heard that he lied to
smaller circles he did yeah which by the
way is a girthy [ __ ] what you ladies and
guys want I don't think so I think you
want long and slender yeah you wanna you
wanna a penis that's been intimate in
fasting that's what you want yeah there
you go next taste buds that's it
taste bud
um George Santos this is George Santos
he's 34. he doesn't look great he looks
like an old he's 34. looks like an old
Dominican woman yeah and he gets 34 year
old man it's like Cheech Marin from here
anyway I don't have my glasses well the
thing is you know when you're when
you're harboring all those lies is that
bold on top I can't see is that a bowl
on top
um it's like the comb over presidential
okay got it
um so by the way love your new balances
thanks um I got new balance on too oh
you know high top New Balance guy I love
a high top they're not common yeah I
love it it's from Amy Lee uh diori
whatever ald you know what I'm saying
Amy Leon door I like those where did you
find those I got um very old-school shoe
right there yeah yeah I I got them on
you know what you ready for a little
trick please are you ready I didn't do
it with this one but I've done it with
multiple clothing items and shoes and I
know people might say you're don't do
that but I'm it's just listen it's not
only about saving money but it's
actually sometimes these things are more
comfortable can I guess what you did go
ahead no you threw me on the last thing
sometimes they're more comfortable
what do you think I did something
suspect
she doesn't close it's just a I would
call it it's a um it's uh uh it's not it
hack it's a hack it's a life hack it's a
life hack okay so tell me tell me just
the synopsis what you do so these
sneakers I didn't do it with okay
sneakers I just went and ordered regular
but I'm saying what I would do
I guess not no so much with like a name
brand but for example I saw these uh
boots like a like a boot but it's also
like a sneaker like a fun casual Boot
and I saw Rob Gronkowski looks like a
pump feels like a sneaker you know what
that is um that's some women women's
heels or something yeah easy Easy Spirit
Easy Spirit easy access Yes Yes actually
you know it's funny you mentioned that
shout out pretty grinder shout out
Brittany Greiner
um AKA Drake you so when is she coming
home I mean that's tough
we got to get a home I got news for
yourself in those eight weeks
she came I don't belong I don't believe
she came home did she really she came
home she literally came home yeah we
traded her for we traded her for The
Merchant of death okay from Russia and
he he also he also went home okay he's
in Russia yeah and now it's it's very
interesting they're like oh the war has
changed and Ukraine was winning and now
Russia's beating the [ __ ] of them and
nobody can understand why but The
Merchant of death some of us think has
something to do with okay okay but but
we traded The Merchant of death for
Britain I didn't know when she's home
great great she's home
um dude what about the coin do you know
the queen did the Queen of England die
before you died
she's died she died Queen of England
died but she must have died before he
died right maybe I just didn't read the
news then maybe I just didn't read the
news
no no Queen of England died before he
passed he was alive
but sometimes you know what it took
weeks to bury her right yeah I might not
have read the news I did take weeks to
bury her it was crazy it is weird though
Sal does feel like a Jesus figure
I mean yeah Matt this is Jesus I didn't
know Jesus was going to come back with
New Balances but I like it I mean I'll
take whatever you want to call me these
days I'm just happy to be here oh no so
what was I just saying you were telling
me about what you do with the shoes so
he has to have the clothes so what I do
is let's say I saw these these Boot
shoes that actually Rob Gronkowski was
doing a commercial fun I was like I like
those but when I went online to get them
I'm forgetting the company they were
like 400 and I was like not gonna do
four hundred dollars I'm already you
know upset my friend died I'm not gonna
do 400 so what I did was is I took the
name of that shoe company which again
I'm blanking on maybe with the V and I
put it in the search engine on Amazon
all shoes just like that one that are
knockoffs most of them I think from
China are knockoffs pop up 40 bucks 60
bucks 80 bucks you buy that shoe they
look identical I got a pair they are the
most comfortable shoes I've ever had for
not a third of the price it's a huge
thing it's a huge Market what would your
mother website you want to they do it
with sneakers no I just went on Amazon
oh I did it on the Amazon app because
it's an actual there's actual websites
in China that you can go on because they
they counterfeit sneakers right right
and I and when I got obsessive about it
I ordered a bunch of counterfeit
sneakers to compare them to my sneakers
just to see well the counterfeit tickets
weren't that much money no of course
well no then China has your address
that's why I was afraid oh well okay
yeah well China yeah yeah
uh the CCP does watch this podcast
though
let's say I ordered like five or six
pair uh two joke terrible two uh you
know I I I maybe uh but you see if if
you had them side by side two couldn't
tell if you were an expert really so I
was like wow just a crap shoot but yeah
two I would and that was actually both
like
it was disappointing and encouraging and
a little bit away because I was like
well F that like I paid a lot of money
you know money for these but like then
the other side of it was like well all
right I'll I'll keep these other ones
and now so but I'm sure they weren't
made with the same materials but you're
saying that as comfortable they're as
not that I've tried on the Gronkowski
shoe I'm sure it's very comfortable but
I felt like the shoe that I got for 70
bucks off Amazon is comfortable
affordable and I'm gonna continue to
look for items that I like
that are expensive and put them in the
search engine in Amazon and buy it from
the Chinese children order them from
Chinese children that's what I think the
right thing to do is
judge counter do you judge that at all
if you found out your friend had fake
shoes on and was wearing them earnestly
uh all right do I judge someone who's
telling me something's real when it's
fake yeah that's a bit of a lie that's a
little bit of a George Santos to me
we'll call now I mean if someone has
counted for choose I could care less my
favorite counterfeit true story is Jim
Norton in one of his comedy specials
were fake Yeezys the whole time and he
and he's terrible they're like falling
apart you could see but did he was he
open about that or what did he think
they were real you just it was a bit by
the way we should probably fill sell in
oh that's something you missed he's dead
no he's not president he is missing
Kanye no Mr President he's not president
he has come out as a Bastion for Jewish
culture
close Okay Kanye has come out as a Nazi
Kanye is a Nazi Wes Kanye West Kanye
West yay yay has come out as a Nazi and
even worse news
Kim Kardashian and Pete Davidson
no more no no no no no no more no more
oh that's that's sad yeah but but what
happened
what happened
I think what happened was with well with
Kanye coming out as a Nazi yeah that's
tough I mean at least he still has
Balenciaga Adidas all that stuff just to
wait
a Nazi he's a full Nazi Kanye came out
as a full Nazi on Alex Jones in a ski
mask
that's good that's not true yeah yeah it
is it because people were and and people
were saying that when all this happening
we were getting so many messages they
were like we just hey babe would respond
to this we just said hey babe respond to
this missed the old days and I said I
there's nothing I can do so what's he
doing now Kanye he's missing actually he
genuinely is truly missing is he really
missing no no he really actually is
isn't that wild like but he's missing to
everyone yeah missing missing his
management came out and said we have no
idea what Kanye is nobody actually knows
where Kanye is but the media doesn't
care to me he doesn't care so do we
think that Kanye is just off isolated
because he's feeling some heat or do we
think God forbid
despite being a Nazi but do we think
something happened he's not I think was
he Greta thundberg to step in and help
to find that I personally think it's our
job here at the hey babe podcast to find
Kanye
I think we if Kanye's missing we need to
find lists the listeners like I put out
an APB listen
we want you here right now to listen to
us and listen good there's an APB out on
Black Mountain ski mask that's what
you're looking for yeah a black not
seeing the ski mask
with a hundred million dollars probably
in cash Balenciaga outfit and Yeezy
shoes he's probably in the Wyoming area
yeah he did text oh he has another thing
that you missed in the last in the last
eight weeks you ready should we tell him
this one Kanye out of the blue texted
Shane Gillis
[Laughter]
come on that's a joke that is not a joke
Kanye out of nowhere texted Shane Gillis
about a week ago oh no about four weeks
ago
do you reaction really not know this get
back on Mike get back with me oh my God
wait there was so many questions okay
so they suggested it they suggested it
okay because I said French food and they
said we were thinking the same thing and
you know what it is what's great about
frequents where it is it's on Greenwich
Street New York City
parking you we parked right in front of
the restaurant Thursday 650 right in
front of the rest right in right in you
enjoyed the meal love the meal
yeah up top up top yeah but but pace
we split ski split screen two cards
cement split two cards because you talk
about tip and match tip Matt you have to
we match the tip identical okay I you
didn't like say it and then put extra
five or something like that no I was
gonna but I didn't want to do that you
know but I but I did tip the coat rack
people five okay right so yeah the coach
so
the people who were installing the coat
rack yeah so wait okay okay so we've got
an endive salad okay uh uh uh Endive
salad grape bread
um then you ready for this they had a
salad with the dressing was mustard ice
cream
also they're doing things over there
mustard ice cream they're in the game
over there They're Playing for Keeps
then I said to my friend who is
gluten-free who ordered the salad with
mustard ice cream I said doesn't the
mustard ice cream have gluten he said I
never thought about it uh but I guess it
wouldn't how is that car right what do
we got
okay
okay so we're gonna
we will get to the end what is the name
of the hotel that the restaurant is in
the hotel the restaurant is on the first
floor of the hotel Phuket it's faquettes
hotel and then for Quest bronzieri is it
the old Tribeca Grand might be okay it's
on Greenwich okay okay
here we go
wow wait wait wait wait no no no how is
this possible wait what wait wait wait
wait wait sorry what happened look
it says what is he training for uh
I don't even I don't Is that real
what the [ __ ] he's jumping over so
there's a Chinese man who's ripped
holding dumbbells jumping over boxes of
Girl Scout cookies and then it looks
like it and then jumping over them
they're jumping over them backwards
crotch clears six feet easily easily the
only way that he could have accomplished
this feat intermittent fasting that's
the only one
this I I don't even understand what I'm
looking at I thought it was fake this is
uh yeah he's um you can ever get would
you ever even want to put in the time to
get that ripped no I you're so you look
at a guy's body like that and you say
I'm fine not I'm fine never looking that
way fine fine yeah that's too much it's
too much dedication to one thing you
don't want to do it
oh that's another thing liver tank who
we will talk about all the time we would
Pat you know the liver King on Instagram
we love the liver King you know he would
eat the organs of of uh animals livers
of animals and for like protein I
thought we talked about liver King
didn't we talk about liver King I've
been dead so liver King came out and
said that he's actually on steroids oh I
know this guys he have beard and long
hair yeah
so he was saying that I just want to be
honest with you guys I'm on steroids and
we were like yeah we know
he's like guys sit down I mean look at
how I mean so liver King you should
really invest probably in crypto now too
oh crypto remember how we went through
the roof
going through the roof
I missed out on the boom you missed out
on the boom okay you missed out on the
crypto boom We it is who's leading that
charge the guy what's that that FTX guy
FTX Now's the Time to get involved okay
FTX is actually they sponsored the show
now so it's all good it's all right
my crypto I would say my crypto is
probably it's in the coffin next to you
crypto is dead and buried no it is I
haven't looked what do you mean it's
just another I'll have another crash
happened yeah crypto yeah it's it seems
over it seems like over everyone's
getting arrested
starting to get arrested nft people
I was first talking about it yeah Sal
did
what I say before my death so you want
me to send you money for an invisible
thing that could just disappear yeah I'm
not doing that yeah yeah most people
didn't get involved the nfts I didn't
get involved the whole thing is truly
truly truly truly like Justin Bieber got
an nft for six million or whatever and
now it's 300. right yeah right no
remember the board Apes we looked at
them on an episode yeah yeah all those
are worthless well there well they were
worthless but the thing is the
celebrities are now starting to get
collected and arrested because they got
paid in crypto to promote crypto
well what's wrong with that if I don't
know that I'm gonna get paid in money to
promote anything I mean I don't know
it's a new thing I don't know I don't
really understand what's going to happen
yeah well also no one knows who created
it
yeah you know like so wait so what about
all the blockchain and this is tied to
me and no one else has it and all those
things are useful but the people at the
top were like Pirates
imagine a pirate mate question you're
telling me every single every single
crypto company
no not every single one but it's really
but the bottom is falling out and you it
looks like there's gonna be no
recovering
no what do you think I don't know if
there's gonna be so if you talk to
certain people
um if you talk to certain people in the
crypto digital space hey Shout Out Tank
Sinatra they will tell you that certain
experts they will tell you that Sal tank
Sinatra the influencer on social media
is giving him a free trip to Costa Rica
what do you think of that who me me and
and Jazz we got we got a free trip to
Costa Rica all we got to do is all we
got to do is I'm turning over in my
grave
what do you think should we go for what
reason just because he got an
opportunity to bring people to Costa
Rica
for like a three four day stay or at
this new resort in Costa Rica and he was
like it's all paid for flight hotel he
has to do the influencing from me he's
got to do and he's like oh but you don't
have to do anything do you do memes yes
he does meme
it's the company whale bone we know
whale bones
shout out well bone I will wear their
products they actually I love well I'm
so busy and I've died but that's the end
they asked me to make they asked me to
make a hat with them like to design a
hat are you going to do it yeah I I was
like are you kidding me dream come true
I would love to do something like that
you should design it what happened six
months ago I haven't gotten back to them
yet you should design them like the app
that we wore in hey babe I know that I
should I should make that hat better
better
so it's a whale bone ascending tanks
Costa Rica they actually are getting
involved with Comics too they throw like
comedy nights or something yeah I did
the show Once okay but here's the thing
with Costa Rica I is and I just want to
talk it out I've been there I don't want
to go is that is that what part of Costa
rics I have no idea they just said Costa
Rica they said a new resort and the
thing the reason why I don't want to go
is this just hear me out just hear me
out I don't want to go because any place
that's tropical and beautiful like that
which great but it is just beach
activities and hotel beach I feel like I
can do that here I'm a history guy I
want to go to a place that has a beach
and all that fine but then also has
history and and things like Barcelona
Barcelona yeah Barcelona would be
amazing
but I don't want to go to Costa Rica
Jasmine wants to but I I don't want to
Nash
I think it's a direct flight they said
it's four and a half hours yeah did you
what is what was your experience at
Costa Rica okay I went maybe I want to
say nine nine years ago or something
like that okay I went with a good group
solid group okay
um we originally we're going to be in a
condo from some guy got a timeshare we
got into account okay we got there and
the condo was cool but it was off the
beaten path so we switched to a hotel
right on the beach side there and I had
a nice time there okay I had it I we
went we went to the mountains one day
and did like a hike to the waterfalls
and it was pretty dope did I ever tell
you this and at the top of the mountain
they they have this like cements water
slide that goes all the way back down so
you don't walk back down but then it's
cutting everyone's up but then a cement
water slide yeah it's weird it's like I
think it's cement it's but it's like
Smooth doesn't it there's water flowing
down it maybe it was maybe it wasn't
cement I don't know I remember being
cement I have pictures of it but anyway
I'm going down this freaking water slide
right I swear to you we go I I took surf
lessons Okay we walked around the town
it was nice you know but I don't know
yeah the water wasn't crystal blue or
anything though it was like regular like
here water interesting it might have
been cleaner but it wasn't that crystal
blue stuff anyway I went down that slide
it's like an eight minute slide back
down
like it took and you're flying down the
slide you know you're going at a decent
clip yeah but it's like twisty it's not
like looped it's more like you know it's
it's really more straightforward right
but there's some curves but it's not
like it's it's as much to get back down
as it is for like it's not really like
an entertainment thing but but I'm I'm
about 25 of the way down and a goddamn
snake I I turn and I see a snake in the
water in the slide behind me like six
seven feet behind me a snake like a big
snake I can speak like that oh my God oh
my God I don't give a [ __ ] and then in
Costa Rica I don't know who this guy is
[ __ ] I don't know who the snake keeps
time with and we're going down I'm
screaming I'm like it's a [ __ ] thing
it's a [ __ ] snake behind me again I'm
looking back I'm sliding through I shoot
out into the pool and the snake they
have it on video The Snake shoots right
out answer me I ran I jumped out of the
[ __ ] Lake like the little like pond
in the front a snake rode the whole
thing down with me and could have easily
bitten you done anything a while
like a Costa Rican free bird snake just
out in the open I just hopped on the
thing I turned at one point I curved and
I saw a [ __ ] snake and I was like I I
I you can't move no you're going You're
the torque the centrifugal I don't know
whatever that thing yeah it came off
yeah no I was just you're on the ride
with the snake and that snake was coming
after you uh
he really wanted anything to do with me
but he was going down and he had no
choice either
so moral of the story don't go to Costa
Rica I would go not go on a slide okay
don't go on a spot speak it speaking of
slides yeah you know when I got my kids
for Christmas which by the way you
missed Christmas happy belated Chris you
were dead for Christmas you missed
Christmas yeah Santa's still good
everything's good but I got my kids it's
called this it's called the stair slide
you literally it's pieces of a slide
okay I could show it to you okay I'll
show it to you it's pieces of a slide
that you connect to the stairs and then
the kids slide down the stairs
it is an absolute
broken bone waiting to happen yeah I was
like how's that even no literally I used
to go down like a cardboard box down the
steps no no no no the TT Jerry slid down
it slid through the door slid down it
slid through it home alone yeah yes it's
not the front door slid through the door
it literally is the stair slide if you I
mean my kids love it that's the only way
they go downstairs but I'm gonna show
this thing to you have you taken it yes
no well it says 175 pounds wow no
intermittent fasting hasn't got me
though more days I went from 251 to 219.
oh yeah man yeah in three four months
um God bless about this stair slide is
if you get this for your kids have 9-1-1
on speed dial my kids are flying down
this thing every day and I'm like how is
this product legal but they but well
because they say you know it's the
warning's all over like this is used at
your own risk use at your own risk use
at your own risk because they know that
kids are gonna [ __ ] Crush themselves
and they still make it they still make
it but there's gotta be it's gonna be
something like like it's gonna be videos
popping up of this thing on online well
there was a guy when I looked on how to
connect it there was a guy on YouTube
he's like do not buy this product every
single one of my kids bleeds after they
get on this goddamn slide and uh but
yeah that was your Lebanese neighbor or
yeah no so
let me tell you so that the speaking of
board age I got a whole bunch up here
still they have a sculpture Shane and
Kanye I still need they have a 100
000 sculpture on the first floor of
fuckwitz of an ape with a hat on that
has the American flag it actually looks
like an ape that might be special needs
but it's a hundred thousand dollar
is that a shot at Americans might be a
special needs eight with an American
with the biggest fattest ass it might be
like look at these fat ass Americans
coming in here right yeah so
um but I would say the uh our neighbor's
got a cheeseburger it was like a if if a
French if freaking Ratatouille made a
Big Mac it was the best burger I've ever
had in my life really yeah now you have
my interest I think it's odd to go to a
French restaurant and then order a
burger though but the reason why she did
it because we said the same thing we
[ __ ] on her right away we're like you're
you know we just really were like you
dumb your [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] this is
why people don't like your country [ __ ]
the Middle East like we really went in
yeah we were like Saddam should have
gotten you right you scumbag [ __ ]
even the French waiter came out and
started slapping her around a little bit
that's right yeah yeah and then he takes
it and you're like me again well no she
said she said the reason why I got a
cheeseburger in a French restaurant is
because guess what it comes with french
fries
they call them just fries exactly did
you say they call it just soup yeah how
do you order french toast at a French
restaurant then because you're just
gonna order toast well I was gonna say
that they just came out the Bread Basket
was French toast when they came out with
the bread it was just if you want french
toast though and you say I want toast
then they bring you toast that must be a
real difficult thing it was very no
that's what I mean they literally all
the when we got to the rest I mean we
had you know dinner reservations at 6 30
it was just bottles of syrup and toast
in the basket because their toast is
always French it's just always French
French toast
are they the first people to kiss with
tongue why do they get the name do you
know the very first the very first time
I tongue kissed a girl I'm talking about
the number one very first time you
frenched someone the very first time I
frenched someone in sixth grade I I'm
talking about the fur not this not one
of the first the first time I got
mononucleosis not the first time
that really set the tone for your life
for the rest of my other kissing another
person I've got Epstein-Barr varies that
doesn't go away the very and it's made
me chronically fatigued for upwards of
28 years out the [ __ ] who did it yeah
not the guy out the guy yeah out the guy
no her name was uh I think her name was
Alyssa Alyssa was her name I don't
remember what her name is she's watching
and we know she gaming mono I got an
enlarged spleen and I had to miss three
weeks of school oh my God the first then
the very first time I had sex the very
first time I had sex I did not use a
condom and I did not pull out and I had
a pregnancy scare that was the first my
first encounters with love wow right
yeah and when you give oral you get a
sore throat and every time I do all I
get a sore throat wow somebody put a
sexual hex on you yeah sex if you will
that's a set yeah and actually the best
part of [ __ ] what's the reason why you
absolutely need to go to focus yeah this
has been hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe
hey babe